people of the internets retro rein who
are here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and boy my
fellow witches and wizards do we have
some really big news massive news I
would say to talk about today regarding
not only Hogwarts Legacy possible DLC
for the game it's overall future but
also the future of Wizarding World video
games as a whole MMO anybody want an MMO
because I think we might be getting an
MMO now Hogwarts Legacy of course
released in February of 2023 on current
generation platforms to both commercial
and critical success they sold 12
million copies in the first two weeks
alone and followed that up with releases
on the PS4 and Xbox One Last Summer most
recently they launched the game on the
Nintendo switch just in time for the
holiday season all of this added up for
the bestselling game of 2023 with
Hogwarts Legacy even topping the latest
Call of Duty aeat no other game had
accomplished since Red Dead Redemption 2
I mean for real guys we are talking some
major Heavy Hitters here now we have an
official number courtesy of WB Games and
confirmation that Hogwarts has sold wait
for it
22 million copies including 2 million in
the month of December alone we are
talking truly massive sales numbers here
people I mean just for the sake of
comparison a little game called Grand
Theft Auto 4 sold around 25 million
copies the original Red Dead 24 million
copies Super Mario Odyssey roughly 27
million copies these are some of the
bestselling games of all time and
Hogwarts Legacy is at 22 million after
one year I mean imagine if they actually
do release some sort of DLC and have
another push for this game all the sales
that they can keep doing whenever the TV
show finally hits I mean there's going
to be so much opportunity for this game
to keep selling so not surprisingly WB
seems to be very pleased with this
Warner Brothers interactive
entertainment president David haad
recently talked to variety and he talked
specifically here about how proud he was
of hogwart's Legacy and the fact that it
pleased so many of the fans it brought
Harry Potter to life in a new way for
gamers where they could be themselves in
this world in this story and that's what
the team at Avalanche set out to do when
they were developing the game and I
think that's really why it resonated so
well and Remains the bestselling game of
the year in the entire industry
worldwide yes yes 100% yes I am so glad
to see someone at David hadad's level
who really seems to get it and
understand you know there's been all
that talk of live services and adding it
to their games possibly games in the
Wizarding World which he talks about
that here in a second but this quote
alone shows me that he at least
gets and understands why Hogwarts Legacy
was such a big success now despite all
of that success they were shut out of
the game awards and they did not receive
any nominations they did make an
appearance on the People's Choice list
but did not make it to the final round
of voting even so the people have spoken
with their wallets here so where does
that leave us in terms of the future of
Hogwarts Legacy as well as Wizarding
World video games hayad did make note of
Harry Potter quiddit Champion stating
that the game was still in beta testing
of course a number of Gamers have
already had an opportunity to try out
Harry Potter quiddit Champions developer
unbroken Studios conducted a series of
private play test sessions last year and
although many have had an opportunity to
test out the game we still aren't sure
how closely it will resemble the final
product we also don't yet have an exact
release date nor do we have any
confirmed platforms of course many fans
were surprised and some even
disappointed that quidditch was not part
of a Hogwarts Legacy it's explained the
way in the game is being canceled by
Phineas black a character known as the
worst Headmaster in the history of
Hogwarts according to hey we don't have
any particular announcements on exactly
how and when the quiditch game is going
to come to the market but we are working
to get it designed in a way just to
Delight fans it wasn't just quiditch
Champions though no there's another much
shorter quote that's really catching the
eye of a lot of people and
understandably so now I want to be very
clear here on this next part as to what
is coming from variety and what is
coming from heat so first off we have
just a variety quote which says hayad
and Company are already working on
follow-up additions to the Potter versus
Video Game World note the plural there
additions in the next line though they
give us even more information and a
quote from haad directly that includes
the previously announced title featuring
quidditch the wizard sport that was left
out of Hogwarts Legacy to fans Chagrin
which is currently in the beta testing
phase but also a series of other things
that are currently unannounced and will
let fans be part of this world and
stories and characters in deeper and
deeper ways and just to be clear the
highlighted portions right there those
are direct quotes that variety
attributes to David hayad now of course
keep in mind Harry Potter magic awaken a
mobile title finally saw its Global
release last year and is still receiving
regular Updates this one is a bit more
microtransaction heavy personally I love
the game and still play it regularly but
I also understand it's not everyone's
cup of tea there's also Harry Potter
Hogwarts mystery another mobile title
that continues to receive new content
but now we have David ha with a direct
quote saying a series of other things
other things plural you guys in in
addition to quid his Champions so let's
break this down here personally I think
we're for sure getting more Hogwarts
Legacy I happen to think it will come in
the form of DLC as well as a sequel down
the road I mean David Hadad essentially
was just gushing there about the job
that Avalanche did with this game and WB
as a whole is really wanting to focus on
their big franchises of which Harry
Potter and The Wizarding World are
certainly one of them now even though I
personally think DLC and a sequel is
coming we don't have official
confirmation of that just yet and this
of course is despite a recent flurry of
new hires from Avalanche software I told
you guys I wasn't going to make a video
every time they put up a new job listing
but they have been continuously posting
additional jobs mentioning The Wizarding
World and Hogwarts Legacy in various
ways there is definitely something going
on at Avalanche software right now those
guys are working on something the other
piece of the puzzle here is wb's push
for more live service elements in their
games WB Discovery president David Zas
laab of course this was a quote we
talked about a few weeks ago that upset
a lot of people now variety wanted to
ask David hey Dad so don't get the two
Davids confused here both top level
Executives in the company but here's
what hey Dad told variety he said the
path to that is the accumulation of
keeping live games launched with new
content keeping our mobile gam Services
vibrant and large launching new content
now I personally don't know exactly what
he means by large launching new content
I guess that means like big mey
expansions to ongoing live service games
now I think this whole push for live
service has led to understandably so a
great deal of concern among fans but
also some hype as well so the concern
would be WB forcing the Avalanche devs
to incorporate live service elements
into say future Hogwarts Legacy titles
in a way that isn't what fans want from
the developer an extreme example here
would be the suicide squad and rock
steady situation now I absolutely loved
the Batman Arkham games and I have not
yet played Suicide Squad so I can't
speak to the quality of the game and how
different it is but I think from
everything we've seen we can pretty much
tell it is going to be a vast departure
from the story-driven action focused
gameplay that was the Batman Arkham
games now the hope and excitement here
would be of course if the executives
like David hayad really understand why
Hogwarts Legacy worked which according
to that other quote it seems like he
does so what if they had a completely
separate Studio working on a Potter game
with more life service elements like say
an MMO set in The Wizarding World which
I would personally love to see just not
at the expense of another open world
action RPG from Avalanche software
they've proven themselves I think they
should be given even more freedom with
the next project it seems like WB is
pleased so hopefully they'll continue to
give them the resources they need now
we're not done yet there's even more in
the article here variety went on to say
perhaps there is reason to hold out hope
for downloadable content in Hogwarts
Legacy after all when Warner Brothers
games leadership previously said there
were no plans for those updates I have
been saying this for a while if people
go back and look at that original quote
all they said was that there were no
plans at this time in my mind and I
think a lot of other people's mind it is
an absolute no-brainer to release not
just one but a series of DLC updates to
Hogwarts Legacy I mean there are 22
million copies of this game out there
you have just a massive base of people
and fans ready and familiar with your
game now of course they're not going to
get 22 million people to buy a DLC but
if you get even just a small percentage
of that that is a ton of people spending
money on your game even though it's not
live service elements and it also
continues to keep the Hogwarts Legacy IP
relevant and at the Forefront of
people's minds which I absolutely think
is a big Focus for WB now hatyad also
told variety when you ask what our goals
are it's really that macro goal of
making sure that we get as much
engagement with the fans as possible
using content and releases and updates
and live Services now that quote gives
me hope that we're going to see sort of
a multi-pronged approach here not
relying solely on a huge multiplayer
game with microtransactions but a number
of titles and a number of strategies if
you will to appeal to different
audiences in The Wizarding World fandom
and if live services are just say one
component of that I am totally okay with
that it's only going to help even more
people even more fans of The Wizarding
World find a game that they can really
resonate with now me personally you guys
know I already be playing all of them
now DLC or not there are still new
things and some really dark secrets to
be discovered in Hogwarts Legacy there
are actually 11 random NPCs across the
open world who died in mysterious ways
and you guys already know I just had to
get to the bottom of it I made a video
all about it so you can find them too
check it out here on the left side of
your screen now as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon